don't sneeze do those basic things you
idiot hello there I'm nervous yeah me
too I was gonna say the same thing we
just spend the last half an hour set up
these mouse traps 150 miles back so we
could just set them all off in a chain
and watch them do this yeah yeah but um
I kind of feel like I want to see you
just go and put your hands what is this
yeah so shall we
fine let's do it well that Daniel so I
will look at the slow-mo camera I'm
doing it you can go wherever you want
pretty yeah
you
oh my tremendous week what amazing
experiment Oh God yeah you know when you
get a bit here it's it's your nail yeah
I got one directing my thumbnail it
kills that was really successful that
went perfectly
my hands are in pain so my heart is
returned to normal oh your heart steady
I'm glad you're okay
why dissemble up oh you did yeah true
that one we got the chain reaction going
it with yeah let's go got some chain
reaction and like the big match at the
same time like they went so high because
it will flung each other like this high
there's a great moment where your face
is just so scrunched up everybody
mousetrap it's in the air what an
amazing shot is really cool all right
well let's err get rid of these be sure
to follow us on Twitter and subscribe to
the slow mo guys yeah
you
thanks video